tell us why
you were so convinced that the moon
landing was a hoax and what gave you
this idea that it was a hoax
well i grew up as the biggest supporter
of the moon landings my dad was in the
air force he was an officer
he got a packet at the time of the
alleged moon landings of publicity 9x12
color pictures i had them up on my wall
for 10 years saw them every day from the
age of four to fourteen
which is three thousand six hundred and
fifty times and then um i saw a
television show with this gentleman by
the name of william casey on it he
worked as a contractor for rocketdyne
during the apollo program for six years
he had very high security clearances
because he would edit communications
going from the top generals back and
forth to correct their grammar and
everything so they wouldn't look
immature and so he saw a classified memo
from von braun
who said the odds of going to the moon
successfully on the first attempt with
1960s technology was a one in 10 000
chance
and so he saw all these departments
being shuffled around all the time just
as soon as somebody
got their full understanding of what
they were doing they would shuffle
everybody around they were doing
departmentalization
so no one could see the full picture
that the equipment certainly couldn't do
it i mean here's the simplest proof it's
simply logical
what they're claiming is that they went
a thousand times farther than they can
send astronauts today
50 years ago on the first attempt with
one millionth the computing power of a
cell phone i mean when they flew across
the atlantic for the first time a few
years later hundreds of aircraft and
thousands of aircraft were flying across
the atlantic
when they went to the north pole and
south pole here on earth they never made
it the first attempt it took multiple
times
and there's never been a technological
achievement that no one could repeat 50
years later it's like me telling you
50 years ago
toyota made a car that could go 50 000
miles on a gallon of gasoline and yet
today five decades later the best car
can only go 50 miles per gallon or 1 000
the distance you would laugh and say the
original claim is preposterous and so
here we are 50 years later and now the
farthest they can send an astronaut to
the moon is one thousandth the distance
that they claim to have done on their
first attempt 50 years ago with less
computing power than a cell phone one
millionth of the computing power it just
doesn't add up it's the only
technological achievement that could not
be repeated 50 years later it's never
happened it's also the only time that
they deliberately destroyed a technology
i mean the b-52 is 70 years old and
there's still 200 of them in service and
yet they admit they destroyed all the
apollo equipment
and they're claiming they have to go
back to the moon and recreate it from
scratch they destroyed all the original
videotapes all the original blueprints
you would never do that if you really
went you would only do that if there was
a fraud and you were trying to cover
your tracks so if you like this sort of
short clip from an interview i did click
over here to watch the entire interview
and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]